you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess calm
and I'm going to try three tactics
puzzles and just share my train of
thought along the leg okay
playing is black in this first one and
it rings a bell feel like I have seen
this puzzle before okay what do we do
here hmm
I think there's some fancy ce3 move to
create a passed pawn notice if this is
played on move one in some way or
another black will be able to have a
passed pawn at least for a moment when
there's this tension and you push one of
your pawns up and create even more
tension one way or the other there's
going to be a passed pawn that you can
force through c3 takes you could take
like this and pass pawn c3 takes like
this you could take on b2 and you have a
pass on can we do this and have the
rooks off and get this move in so oh
yeah I think I see it
this rook first White has to recapture
and then we play rook to f1 this force
is on the rook and block but the best
move would be king to d2 and then we hit
them with c3 and now that's hitting with
check on takes pawn we capture and even
if the rook comes over to 8th a 7 he's
not going to be there in time
notice when we're giving this check
we're now controlling the promotion
square so chop-chop check King D to c3
takes takes rook a7 push rook takes pawn
we push again and we're there in time I
think there may be one little trick that
y can try after captures recapture check
here push takes takes instead of playing
rook to a7 white can first play rook to
g7 check this is an important detail
corner then rook a7 not only threatens
to take this prawn and then be in time
to track down our past a pond but
they're also threatening mate so I think
that detail I think our the correctly
apply to rook g7 is to simply play to f8
if they take the h7 pond then well
actually our pond will not even be
captured by the rook we'll get a a queen
they won't even be able to sack the rook
for our our queen so yeah if G 7 happens
we'll play King to F 8 this must be the
idea following up with c3 and then
taking and on this check very important
detail King f8
and that's as far as it goes that's the
last little test King in the corner rook
a seven hits with the dual threat of
mate and rook takes here and this pawn
will be tracked down in time all right
let's try number two team light
okay for whenever the reason my first
thought was Bishop here not sure what
that's doing on second thought this
queen is also very short on squares she
only has one safe square she can move to
let's see how we could control these two
squares a4 yes we could control b5 but
after she goes to b6 then there's d8
that she can run away to ah but wait see
what just happened there I said I said
if the Queen gets to b6 then she'll be
able to get to da and we're not going to
be able to stop her from running away
but suppose on move 1 we stop the Queen
from going to be 6 Bishop to c7 Queen
doesn't have this square everything else
is controlled these Knights are
controlling these four squares that must
be I don't see anything against the King
is you've got a bunch of defenders our
rook isn't going to be attacking here
this is a trap the Queen type position
just noting that she's really short on
squares yeah that must be what it is
we're not going after the King here
we're pursuing the Queen trap and it's
got to be moved 1 and now we just hit
him with a 4 Queen trap okay yeah I was
I was ready to do a 4 first but Queen B
6 then she runs away so you have to stop
that
Queen b6 move first and then hit them
with a four okay let's try the last one
three of three
ooh okay
Queen versus two minor pieces clean
versus light square Bishop and Knight
okay we also have a pawn but what's the
trick here wears black vulnerable this
Bishop is unprotected we have a check
with the bishop on h6
what more no good Queen checks bishop
controls this the rook isn't going to
contribute there's no double attack of
the bishop and let's say h6 that I see
hmm oh this move this is the only way to
rattle the coordination of these pieces
f4 we have a one piece supporting it
directly but also indirect support
because regardless of what order black
captures away on f4 whether it's a
knight or a dark square bishop that
remains on this square Queen d4 Wilfork
the King and Bishop so the idea with f4
is to next play f5 and chase away the
bishop from defending the knight this
must be what it is because I don't think
the Queen and Bishop alone are enough to
do any damage to black 2 to pull off
some kind of a fork
if this night was I don't know some
other square where we could play Queen
to e3 a double attack against the bishop
and h6 that's a different story
but I don't see a way to take advantage
of the h6 square and the bishop on e5
with just the Queen and Bishop and these
are the only two sensitive points I'm
focused on so the other the other piece
or pawn that needs to contribute is this
guy here
f-for if there's some kind of a night
move to be four we have multiple replies
I don't think that's the variations
going to go for night to be four Queen
efore comes to minds we're attacking the
bishop and our queen is hitting the
knight he's just going to an undefended
square so we should be able to take
advantage of that
yeah Queen here makes a lot of sense
moving forward a little bit more central
and she's hitting everything so it must
be just bf4 and they're just going in
with the capture and like I said
regardless of the order black went with
whether it was a knight or a bishop that
on that Square Queen d4 is going to pick
it up and that should be a puzzle solved
not a bad group of three anyhow as usual
feel free to share maybe how you did
with these three tactics puzzles in the
comment section below as usual I hope
you maybe got a thing or two from it and
I will catch you soon
that's all for now take care